المعمل القومي للصحه العامه في الخرطوم
الذي يقع على بعد امتار من القياده العامه
للجيش التي تشهد اشتباكات مسلحه متكرره
خلال الايام الاخيره المعمل اصبح مصدر قلق
على المستوى الدولي حيث اعلنت منظمه الصحه
العالميه على لسان المدير التنفيذي لاداره
الطوارئ بها الدكتور مايكل ريان ان الفرق
الميدانيه تقيم الوضع
الخطوره تكمن في احتواء المعمل على عينات
من فيروسات وبكتيريا خطيره كالحصبه
والكوليرا والتي اذا ما انتشرت في الظروف
الصحيه الحاليه
ستتسبب في كارثه لن يستطيع اي من الاطراف
المتصارعه علاجها هناك شحف المستلزمات
الطبيه والادويه
والعاملين في القطاع الصحي يمكن ان
يتحركوا بامان من منازلهم الى
المستشفيات المدير العام للمنظمه الامميه
حذر من انه في حال حصولك كارثه بسبب
المعمل البايولوجي فان المرافق الصحيه لن
يكون بمقدورها استيعاب مصابين
30% فقط من مستشفيات الخرطوم تعمل في ظروف
ماساويه ولن تستطيع التعامل مع اي تسرب
فيروسي في حال وقوع المعمل القومي في ايد
غير امينه
كثير من المستشفيات التي خرجت عن الخدمه
والسبب يعود لانعدام الموظفين والعاملين
والمستلزمات الطبيه ما يزيد الوضع خطوره
هو قرب المعمل القومي للصحه العامه من
مناطق ذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
والمتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات